Okay. Well, this week we're going to
talk about biomedical imaging and,
uh, you know, from the first
lecture, as I mentioned,
that one of the biggest advances in
biomedical engineering was the development
of,
of systems for looking inside the body.
And that's what we're going
to talk about, uh, this week,
sort of what's the physics behind some
of these systems? How do they work,
what are their limitations,
and what are the opportunities that
each of them present? And again,
like almost every week's subject, uh,
this one could take up a whole course.
In fact,
there's,
there's three or four
courses on biomedical imaging
that are offered here at
Yale. So we're just going to scratch
the scratch the surface of it.
But what I hope to do is give you some
sense for how these different modes of
imaging work, why they work, why they
allow you to see inside the human body,
and then what the limitations of
each particular technology is.
So these are the kinds of questions that
I hope we'll be able to answer by the
end of this lecture. Next
lecture, what is an image?
Most of you could answer that probably
now, but images come in different forms.
And why is imaging so important to
medicine? You probably already know, uh,
either from what you've read in the
past or from your own experience.
Most of us have had at some point by
the time you're as old as you are,
you've had an image taken of your
body of medical imaging, usually an x.
Um, and uh, so you know, something about
why it's so important, but we'll try to,
to, to amplify on what you already
know, what technologies are available.
And so we're going to survey the different
techniques that can be used and that
are used most commonly. It's a very
rapidly developing field. And, uh,
almost every year there are new
innovations in imaging, new, uh,
sometimes even new methods
that are introduced. Um, and,
um, that, that changed the way
we can see inside the body.
And so I'm going to talk about sort
of a snapshot of what's available now.
And as I said,
illustrate or talk about what some of
the problems are or challenges with each.
What are the limitations in particular?
So in image is a visual
representation of um,
can you get the door again? Sorry. Uh,
it's become a routine thing for us.
A visual representation of some
measurable, a property of a person,
an object or a phenomenon. We're going
to be thinking about medical imaging.
So we're going to be thinking
mainly about images of people and,
and images can be formed and displayed in,
in different ways depending on,
um, on properties of the
object and properties of the
imaging system that you're
using,
that you're using to create the image.
And so you're familiar with
certain kinds of images.
You've all probably taken a
photograph with a camera. Uh,
photography has changed dramatically
since, uh, since you were born, right?
It used to be all on film and now
it's almost all on, uh, on digital.
And, um, so these are different
ways of capturing the same thing.
A photograph is a representation
of what you can see.
It's a representation of how visible
light reflects off of objects.
And so you see the outlines of the objects
and their colors and their textures.
Uh, but it's basically a representation
of how visible light is interacting with
some object.
An x ray on the other hand shows you
something that you can't see on your own.
It allows you to see inside the body,
and this is because it's
not using visible light,
which bounces off of objects like us,
but it's using x-ray radiation,
which is able to penetrate the body.
And so by taking a picture of how these,
uh,
these particular form of
electromagnetic radiation called x,
by taking a picture of how it
penetrates through the body,
you can get an image that represents
something about what's inside.
And the challenge is to know because
you understand the physics of the
radiation,
in this case x rays,
and you understand the equipment
that's used to collect the image,
you should be able to be able to
interpret from your understanding of those
things, what it is that you're seeing
inside the body. And of course,
television is a different kind of
image, uh, presented in a different way.
But another image of something that we
can already see. So two kinds of imaging,
really images that represent to us,
maybe not exactly the way we see it,
but things that we can see and
images that represent to us,
things we can't see, but put it in
a form that we can interpret, right?
And so that's just what this says here,
that uh,
that some images you're just trying to
collect and record what it is that you
can see so that you can look back at it
later and remind yourself of what it was
that you saw. Others, other imaging
systems are really transducers,
right?
They're converting something that you
can't see into something that you can.
We talked about transduction,
uh,
several weeks ago now when we talked
about cell communication and the, the,
uh, the concept of transduction converting
one kind of a signal into another.
In this case,
converting a signal that measure something
you can't see but converts it into
something that you can see.
So d to understand this,
I have to review for you something
that most of you probably already know,
at least at some level.
And that's the electromagnetic spectrum.
And this is a representation of the
variation in properties of electromagnetic
radiation and certain
forms of electromagnetic
radiation are apparent to us
because our, our retinas can
detect it. And that's the,
the visible part of the spectrum,
which I've shown here.
Now what this shows is
the entire electromagnetic
spectrum arranged on a scale
from very short wavelength
up to very long wave length.
And these are in centimeters.
The visible part of the spectrum
is around a micron or so,
or slightly less than a
micron, right? It's, uh,
it's around 400 nanometers to 700
nanometers is the visible spectrum.
Now,
why is this the visible spectrum?
Because when radiation with
this wavelength hits your eye,
it makes a change in the cells inside
your eye and allows your retina to make an
image.
All right?
So it's only light of those particular
wavelengths that can interact
productively with this particular special
biological object called the retina.
And that's all the light that we can see.
But there's electromagnetic radiation
of all different wave lengths outside of
the visible spectrum.
In fact,
one of the things you should notice here
is that the visible spectrum is only a
small piece of the entire spectrum
of electromagnetic radiation.
And you know this already,
there are longer wave length,
there's longer wavelength
radiation called infrared.
So it has wavelengths that are
longer than the, um, then the,
in the visible spectrum,
you can't see these, right?
But some cameras can see infrared,
right? That's how if you,
when you,
um,
when you watch the films from the war in
Iraq where they have these sort of heat
heat, uh, visualization goggles,
they're looking at infrared,
infrared wave lengths.
So there's something in the goggles that
is sensitive to infrared light and it
converts it into visible wavelengths,
which you can see. All right.
Have you ever seen satellite pictures,
uh, where, uh, they used to do this? Uh,
oil companies or electric companies would
take a picture of neighborhoods from
the sky,
right?
Infrared and infrared radiation
is associated with heated objects.
So the higher the
temperature of an object,
the more infrared radiation of
a higher wavelength it emits.
So if you take a picture of a neighborhood
at night using an infrared camera,
you can see how much heat is being
emitted from all the different houses.
And you can identify ones that don't
have enough insulation, for example,
or ones that are wasting heat because
they're admitting it at a higher
temperature.
So these are some examples of,
of using a wave length that are, I can't
detect, but getting information from it.
You also are familiar with
ultraviolet radiation.
So these are wavelengths that are shorter,
shorter than the visible spectrum,
shorter than the shorter than the
part of the spectrum that you can see.
But you can experience the effects of
electro of ultraviolet radiation, right?
If you're out in the sun too long, your
skin turns red, right? You get a sunburn.
That's because your skin
absorbs ultraviolet.
Radiation created a change in
the cells of your skin, right?
Different biological effect.
You're seeing it in a sense, right?
You're only seeing it where the sun hit,
not where your body was in shadow.
All right? But you can detect
that radiation that way. Um,
so if we look at the whole spectrum,
I'm going to go back a slide now,
and this was arranged with the,
with the long wave lengths up at this end,
the short wave lengths down at this end.
The other picture is arranged
in just the opposite way, uh,
with the long wave lengths down at
this end. Radio waves, microwaves,
infrared waves,
the visible spectrum,
ultraviolet x Ray and Gamma Ray.
So these are long wave lengths proceeding
to shorter wavelengths as the wave
length changes. So does the
frequency, they're inversely related.
So as the wave length goes down,
the frequency goes up
and the frequency is related to how
much energy these waves contain.
And so the short wave length
x rays and gamma rays, uh,
carry high amounts of energy,
right?
Ultraviolet rays carry more
energy than visible res.
So frequency goes up as
wavelength goes down.
And so does the energy of
the, uh, of the, um, of the,
of the, uh, radiation.
This diagram here shows you
roughly how big is the wavelength.
So for radio waves,
these are very long waves that are the
size of buildings or bigger than people.
Microwaves are shorter.
They're the size of an insect
infrared waves shorter than that,
the size of a pin point,
the visible raise,
the ones that are retina can
detect are about the size of cells.
Bacteria for example, or
protozoa, ultraviolet rays,
the size of molecules.
And then x rays and gamma
rays are submolecular.
There's sub subatomic in size.
And because of that they have special
properties and that they can actually
change Adams when when x rays and gamma
rays are absorbed into materials because
they're wave lengths are smaller than
the wave lengths of Adams or nuclei,
they can actually interact
with Adams and nuclei.
And one of the things that x rays and
gamma rays can do that other raise don't,
is ionize an object.
They can actually inject electrons
from the atoms inside of a material and
create ions. And the eye is that
they create are often reactive.
And this is what makes, uh,
these, uh, shortwave length,
high energy forms of radiation
biologically hazardous
because they are in the
category called ionizing radiation.
When they hit your body,
they can produce changes in particular
produce atoms or ions from Adams.
These ions can further react.
Sometimes they even react with DNA inside
cells and can cause mutations in DNA
as a result of chemical reactions
that occur. And because of this,
we want to limit the exposure of our
bodies to things like x rays and gamma
rays. I'm going to talk about in the
course of the lecture today and tomorrow,
many of the ways that x rays and gamma
rays are useful for medical imaging.
And that's not surprising because I
already said these are short wavelength,
high energy forms of radiation. They can
penetrate through objects fairly easily.
So things that penetrate are
useful for imaging what's inside,
but the disadvantage of their
penetration is that they can also create
okay
ions in biological damage. So we'll
keep that in mind as we go through.
You know that not only ionizing
radiation causes biological damage,
but I also mentioned the
biological effects of
overexposure to ultraviolet light,
which you've probably all
experienced through sunburn
or some other overexposure.
So these aren't the only kinds of rays
that can have a biological effect,
but they're the ones that
we're most concerned about.
Okay?
Okay.
Questions about that or this,
this is probably a picture that
you've seen before. If not,
I encourage you to review, uh, um, um,
review sort of the physics of
the electromagnetic spectrum.
Okay?
So let's talk about x rays and that is
the form of medical imaging that's been
around for the longest, uh, before x.
As your chapter in your
book. Um, um, describes, uh,
physicians and doctors
relied on hand drawings.
They would draw things so that they could
describe what they sought to others or
so they could remember if a patient
came in and had something abnormal,
they might draw a sketch of it
in your, uh, in their notebooks.
So they would remember how
it looked for next time.
And then photography changed that because
you could take pictures of things and
you could remember them without drawing a,
but we still couldn't look
inside the body, right?
Still couldn't look inside
the body. Well, you could,
but not really very well on living people.
Right?
So a lot about what we knew about
the inside of the body was, uh,
from the science of dissection and
looking inside the bodies of cadavers,
people after they died and learning
about their anatomy that way.
So we knew something about that,
but we weren't able to look
inside the living body. Well,
this Wilhelm Renkin change that.
And Rankin was a physicist who discovered
that rays could penetrate through
solid objects. And um, he, uh,
announced that discovery in
1895 he did an experiment,
which is shown,
uh,
in a diagram in your book where he put
objects in front of an x ray source.
And he was able to show that these x
rays would pass through the object and he
could detect them on the other
side with a, with a film.
So here's two useful properties of x-rays.
One is they can penetrate
through solid objects.
The second is that they can expose film,
film like photographic film
is sensitive to x rays.
And because of this,
then you could imagine taking a picture
of how these rays pastor with solid
object.
Now the other thing that's interesting
about x rays is that they pass through
some solid objects better than others.
The more dense the object is,
the less radiation x ray
radiation that passes through.
So if you expose an x ray beam on an
object that solid at some parts and hollow
in the others,
x rays are going to pass easily through
the hollow part and not so easily
through the solid part.
And so the amount of x ray radiation
that goes through an object is related to
the density through which that x
ray penetrated. And it's these,
these properties that made it
good for taking images by, uh,
by a tea after he discovered that,
um,
that x rays could penetrate
through objects. It didn't
take him very long to say,
well, if it penetrates through solid
objects like bricks and boards,
maybe it'll penetrate
through a person as well.
And took some of the first images, x ray
images of people by looking at the hand,
for example.
And he won the,
the first Nobel Prize in
physics for that discovery.
And so it was one of the things
you could take from this,
from the time that he first announced
at 1896 til the time you won,
what's come to be known as the highest
prize in science took only six years.
So people recognized immediately
the value of this approach,
particularly this approach for medical
imaging. Now, the raid that he discovered,
we now call the x Ray. Um,
initially it was called, uh,
the Rankin ray because he was
the one that discovered it.
And there are some countries that still
refer to a two x rays as Rankin raise.
And so you might hear that
a nomenclature if you, uh,
if you travel or if you're reading
particularly in older textbooks.
So how does it work? Here was the
first kind of experiment that a,
that I described earlier
in x ray source here,
the x ray source is emitting x
rays in all different directions.
Some of them would, uh,
would impinge on this object.
All right.
And,
and depending on the density of the
material with inside this object,
some of the x rays would be absorbed
and some of them would pass through in a
dense part of the object, the x rays
would be absorbed in a less dense part.
More of the x rays would pass through.
And if you put a piece of film or some
kind of a detector behind the object,
then you could create basically a shadow,
right?
Just like a shadow. When you're standing
on the street and the sun is up here,
the light doesn't pass through you.
And so what you see on the ground
behind you is the sun all around.
But a shadow where your body
did not allow the, the, the,
the radiation to pass through. In this
case, you'd see a shadow of this object,
but it could be a more sophisticated
shadow in some ways because the x rays can
penetrate somewhat through dense material
and even better through less dense
material.
So the shadow would be light where there
was density in the object and it would
be dark where there was hollowness
or less density in the object.
Right. That makes sense. So in
this way, and x ray is a shadow,
it's an inverse image of the density
through which the x ray passed.
The diagram over here shows you,
shows you a more sophisticated setup and
the kind of setup that's used for x ray
imaging in patients.
So you have an x ray source and so x
rays are admitted from this source.
And if you didn't confine those x rays
in some ways they'd be admitted in all
directions,
but you can find it so that x rays
are only admitted from one side.
Um, you, uh, let that pass
through a filter because these,
these sources of x ray
generation are not perfect.
They generate waves of
different wavelengths and
still through a filter that
only lets x rays pass through through
a device called a column mater and a
column mater is a physical object that
basically just straightens out of being.
If I had a source of radiation
here, right, and x and, and it was,
it was emitting x-rays, they would,
they would radiate in all directions.
I could put something that was x ray
dense behind it and now they would only
admit to the front.
Right?
But what I would like is if I'm want
to take an image of, of someone,
if I want to take an image of me,
for example,
I would like all those x rays to pass
straight through me so that I knew what
direction all of the rays were traveling
so that when I tried to interpret what
was on the film,
there'd be a one to one correlation
between where the x Ray hit the film and
where it went through my body.
If I've got x rays coming
from all different directions
and that's going to blur
the image, right? So you
need to straighten it out.
So the x rays go in one direction
and that's what a column mater does.
It's shown as a whole here, but
really it's, it's, it's a, it's a,
a sheet with many small pinholes and
these pinholes only allow x rays to go
through if they're going in
the right direction, right?
Ones that come at an angle like
this are going to bounce off,
but x rays that come straight through are
going to pass straight through and hit
the object.
The object is the patient.
So I'm standing here and there's,
and there's something behind me that's
going to detect the x rays that pass
through.
That's something behind is this,
there's a grid also to prevent scatter
to only collect the x rays that are
passing in the right direction because
some of those x rays might've been
deflected as they pass through
the object through me, right?
But I only want to collect the ones that
are going in one direction so that I
will know where the anatomical
object they pass through our,
that hits a fluorescent screen.
And the fluorescent screen is,
is a special material that,
uh,
that emits light when x rays hit it.
So an x ray hits the fluorescent screen,
it generates a lot of
light right in that spot.
And this detector detects the light.
So the fluorescent screen
amplifies the x ray signal.
Several photons of X-ray hit,
they generate fluorescence,
they expose the detector,
right?
And now in the old days,
this used to be really film x Ray film
photographic film that was sensitive to x
rays.
And you would,
the detector is really a piece of film
that you would take out of the machine
and you would, and you would
develop it with chemicals, right?
The same way you develop a, uh, uh,
any other kinds of photographic film.
Now there are detectors that are
electronic and so you can detect things
electronically without film.
If you have an x ray though,
you probably,
if you have one at home at checks
x Ray that your parents gave you,
say you're going off to college, take
your chest sacred. Hey, anybody bring one?
Wow.
Uh, well if you did, it would be
probably a real piece of film.
Um, so, uh,
x rays are formed from high energy
radiation and inverse shadow is created
because x rays pass through Lens,
less dense areas easier.
And what's it going to pass through in
the body if you do a chest x ray of,
uh, of my chest, for example,
where will the x rays pass
through the most easily? Well,
they'll pass through the lungs.
The lungs is primarily air, right?
The lungs is air and tissue,
but it's mainly airspaces.
And so what you see is dark.
Here are the less dense regions are the
lungs where nothing much interfered with
the x rays passing through the body.
All right.
Had to pass through skin soft tissue,
some muscles,
and then primarily through air
where the image is light here.
Those are regions that
absorbed most of the x rays.
So not many of the x rays got through
to hit the film in back of me. Right.
And those, uh, those, those areas
appear lighter. So this bone,
the clavicle appears light.
The ribs up here,
like the bones of the rib cage appear
lighter. What's this object here
in the chest over on this side?
Big
Right?
The heart. Right. And why is the heart
to pure light on this image? Well,
it's not bone, right?
It's not as dense as bone.
It's muscle. It's soft tissue,
but it's also filled with water.
A lot of water, right? And it's
a three dimensional object.
And so for x rays to pass through
this whole three dimensional object,
a lot of the x rays get absorbed, right?
It's a thicker object then this bone.
And so even though it's
not as dense as bone,
it appears wider here because it's thicker
it x rays have to pass through more of it.
In order to get to the other side,
the thicker the region,
it has to pass through the
more opportunity for those
x rays to be absorbed.
The diaphragm.
And what do you think are these scattered
sort of white things all around here?
All around the side here.
Well first,
what's this object that comes
up and sort of off to the side?
Here's the heart.
Something comes up.
Sorry. The Aorta. The aortic arch is here.
Remember from our pictures of the heart,
you can't see it entirely because behind
it is another white object that's sort
of in the mid line here.
That's the bones of the spine.
All right?
And in this region here,
they're all super imposed,
right?
So you can't really tell how much of this
absorption comes from the aortic arch
and how much of it comes from the spine.
So this is one problem with rays
that you're not seeing a three
dimensional image of the chest.
In this case, you're seeing
a projected image, right?
And so you're only looking
in one direction really,
and you're seeing a projection of all
the things that the x rays could pass
through. So I can't tell, for example,
if the aortic arch is in
front of or behind the spine,
I can't even tell where the boundary
of them are because it's all just there
absorbing x rays.
And so I can't see it.
So what if I want it to look at this in
more detail or I wanted to distinguish
what part of this is the aortic
arch and what part is the spine?
How would I change the imaging,
Sarah?
Yeah.
You could ask the patient to turn to
the side and you could then do the same
measurement this way, right? And
now you'd see another projection,
but you see a projection
from another angle.
And so you would be able to differentiate
what is different in this direction,
right?
And you might do it obliquely, you
might ask the patient to turn, you know,
a little bit sideways or, or
uh, or turn the other way.
And by putting together several different
images taken from different angles,
you can learn more about the three
dimensional aspects of what's inside.
You might be able to see things that you
can't in one image in one of the other
angles.
Okay.
So x rays are a projection,
a two dimensional projection
of a three dimensional object.
And that's one of their limitations.
And you can get around that
a little bit by asking the,
by moving the object around and
taking images from different sides.
Another problem with x
Rays is radiation dose.
I mentioned that x rays were
a form of ionizing radiation.
And so if you're exposed to x rays,
you could be generating ions inside
and with a normal chest x ray,
if you only have one chest x ray taken
every five years or 10 years or so,
the dose that you get is relatively low.
Your body has mechanisms for repairing
those, uh, that biological damage,
right?
Your body has mechanisms for repairing
the kind of biological damage that's done
by ionizing radiation.
And so if the dose is low enough,
the risk of some permanent
kind of damage is fairly low.
Where,
okay,
there is a risk is if you have
repeated exposure to higher doses,
in which case you're generating more ions
are being generated in your body than
the repair mechanisms that are
naturally in place can repair.
And then you get tissue damage.
And so one is concerned when you're
using radiation with limiting the dose
that is delivered on each x Ray.
So how could you reduce the dose here?
How could you reduce the radiation
dose that the patient receives?
Thinking about how this thing works,
how could you reduce the dose?
Okay.
Well one is you could use the minimum,
the minimum number of x rays
necessary to see what you want to see.
And of course as you
use less radiation dose,
you're going to see less on the image.
So you're set,
the sensitivity is going to go down.
And so one of the things you might not
see if you use less radiation dose,
you might not see these other structures
here that are barely visible in this
particular image,
right?
And these structures here are vessels
from the pulmonary vasculature and the
Bronc I associated with the lung
and you might care about those.
So you might need a higher dose in
order to see what you want to see.
So you can reduce the dose by reducing
the intensity of the radiation.
But the cost is you don't get
as high a quality of an image,
not as useful for diagnosis.
Um,
one could also make innovations
in the machinery, right?
In particular, you could make detectors
that are always, that get more sensitive.
And the more sensitive the detector is,
the more information you get per, uh,
per photon or per, uh, radiation.
So more sensitive detectors allow you
to make better measurements with less
radioactivity and there have been those
innovations continually over the years.
And so the x rays that you would
get now are fairly low dose x rays,
uh, without much, uh,
apparent risk to you.
You also can limit where
the x rays hit the body.
And part of that is done by focusing
part of it's done by something called
shielding, right? So if you are
getting a checks x ray done,
they might put an apron on your waist.
That apron contains a very dense material
and so the x rays don't penetrate
through below your waist.
All right?
So these are all ways that
that radiologists use to
reduce the radiation dose to
uh, to uh, patients.
Okay.
We talked about being able to see more
by looking at different angles and the
technology called computed tomography or
CT is sort of the end product of that.
It's trying to design x ray
machines and CT machines use x rays.
The physics of how you form
the image is exactly the same.
You're generating x rays and
they're passing through the body.
What's different is that the machine
allows you to take pictures at many,
many different angles while
the patient stays, uh, still.
So instead of asking the patient
to move from one side to the other,
so you can take pictures
of different angles.
You have an x ray source and a detector
that basically spins around the patient.
Yeah.
And it takes pictures at different angles
and you use not a broad beam that's
going to expose my chest
all at the same time,
but you use a narrow collimated beam,
a narrow beam that you can focus
and move throughout all of the,
um, throughout all of the
angles around the body.
So you're not giving a sort of
a plane of radiation anymore.
You're giving something more
like a line of radiation.
Right.
And as that line passes through me,
there's going to be absorbance detected
back here depending on what was in the
way of that particular line of
radiation that was coming through. Now,
any one line doesn't give you
very much information, right.
Any one line of radiation doesn't
give you very much information.
But what if you collect those
lines from all around my body?
You can basically see my
body from every angle.
That still is going to be a
complicated set of images, right?
What if you took 360 pictures as
you spun this thing around my body,
now you've got 360 pictures to look at.
How do you make sense of that? Well,
you couldn't really,
and so what really made CT possible
is that mathematicians figured out in
mathematical ways for taking all of these
separate images that are collected as
you move around the body
and reconstructing and image
of the whole object that
must been in between. All right, that the,
the mathematical process is called
back projection and you take,
you take a large number of
projected images that are
acquired from all different
angles and you can reconstruct a picture
of what the object must have looked
like that it was sampling.
Okay?
Now because it's a narrow beam, you're
doing this in a line instead of a plane,
you're and you're spinning it around,
you're really doing a slice through the
body with each rotation of the device,
right?
If I spend this all around my body,
then I'm basically moving this line
around different angles and I'm looking at
one slice maybe between here
and here all the way around.
And so you can reconstruct an image
of a slice that might look like this.
All right? The digital,
the, the chest x Ray,
a plane of radiation shadow
of what that produces.
The CT gives you a slice,
a transverse slice of the body,
but it shows you the real three
dimensional structure of what's inside.
So what can you see in
this picture? Well, here,
here was the spine and this picture,
is this from the thorax that contains
the lung or is this from the abdomen that
contains the intestines?
Don't read the bottom of the picture,
but just looking at it, it's not the
lungs, right? Because you don't see,
you don't see a lot of dark area in
here that would indicate hair, right?
What you see in stead are a lot of soft
tissues that sort of absorb radiation.
Uh, this here is the liver. You can see,
you can see muscles and bones of the
rib cage, which are down in the abdomen.
Here you can see the spine very clearly.
You can see the kidneys at the back.
You can see the intestines in here.
All right.
And so an experienced radiologist
who's looking at this can see a lot of
information arranged in the
proper three dimensional way.
Now this is one slice,
but you could do another slice as well.
And you can do that in the machine because
the patient is sitting still and is
moving through the machine
one step at a time, right?
So there's a conveyor belt here that's
bringing the patient into the machine.
And in the machine is this rotating
array of x ray sources and detectors.
This part spins around.
So you bring the patient in,
you spin it around, you collect all
the, you bring them in a little farther,
you spin it around each time, each
increment that you move to patient in,
you're taking a picture of another slice.
And so one could take a three
dimensional image of the whole body.
Okay?
Now, because you're just using
line sources of radiation,
one can reduce the amount of radiation
that with each individual picture that
you take,
okay?
Compared to an Xray. But you've got to
take a lot of these pictures, right?
And so the cumulative dose of
radiation, uh, can be significant.
So even though you could take a full
three dimensional picture of your body,
you might not want to do that,
right?
You might just want to take a picture of
the slices that seem to be of interest.
Maybe the abdomen, maybe
the chest, maybe the knee,
if you're having a problem with your knee.
And so CT is commonly used
for head injuries. It's fast.
It's a very effective at
detecting blood in the brain,
for example. So you can
detect that easily. And,
and for analyzing the structure
of bones and you know,
x rays are very good for bones.
If you've had or had a broken bone,
then you've probably seen an x
ray of the bones of your body.
And that's because bones
absorb x ray radiation.
And so x rays are very
good ways to detect it.
Okay.
I think that's where I
want to stop for today. Um,
and we talked about x ray radiation.
I got some slides on here that say a
little bit more about ionizing radiation
and I put them on there for you to read
because it's not in the chapters in the
book. Uh, but this talks about
sources of ionizing radiation, uh,
a picture of sort of what it is and some
of the biological effects of ionizing
radiation. It's sort of beyond what
I'm going to ask you about, uh, in the,
in the exams or anything.
But I wanted you to have that information.
And then next time we're going
to move on and talk about, um,
forms of imaging that
don't require x rays.
And so don't have the biological
risks of ionizing radiation.
We'll talk about ultrasound
imaging and MRI imaging,
and we'll talk about what I think
is going to be a, an important, uh,
imaging technique of the future,
but using light to image inside
the body as well. Okay. Questions?
Okay,
good. Thanks. I'll see you on Thursday.